a girl in jean shorts
[Music]
kind of like properly diverse crowd
Ed
all kind of ethnically ambiguous they're
in a fun field Chicken Fried
it's starting to rain
[Music]
just a bunch of people walking around in
the rain easy to drink easy to enjoy Bud
Light hey conservatives you guys like
blue jeans and that Chicken Fried song
right yeah yeah show them that do that
maybe put one of the girls in a cowboy
hat or boots or something yeah those
Hicks will eat that up they'll forget
about how much we support transgenderism
those roofs they'll buy anything easy to
drink no we won't we won't and we
definitely won't be buying Bud Light